okay we are
live
morning uh we have some stuff to do
today so I think that we're just going
to optimize the heck out of training
today
in
puff we're going to check on our
experiments we ran overnight first
though we got to check on those
there's one thing I want to check on
first which is just the uh this run
versus the previous
run I want to check on the sample
complexity just so that we know whether
our new algorithm is performing as well
as uh as we think it should be able to
okay so this is the one that we had
where it's like really really good
right this gamma Lambda and then if we
look here lambda's all over the place
gamma's whatever because it doesn't
matter in this uh this version
but what we want to look at
is the
why are all of these experiments running
so
right hang on are these
all these are all at like
and so very very weird
there or 100
we also have clearly we have 50 mil
solves for this one as
well right this is a 50 mil solve right
here now it does look like we have a few
somewhat uh faster solves over here mind
you haven't finished the other sweep
yet it's weird that they're all out to
100 Mil
though
right they shouldn't all be up to 100
what end this is breakout so this is
this is our completed sweep over
breakout and you can see we have solves
in a minute and a half and almost solved
and this is under two
minutes so this one is very
good this is just PPO
J but it's weird how the total time
steps is locked to 100 million up top
right like I don't know how it's this
fast at 100
Mil wa a cost graph didn't
we yeah we do have a cost graph so
see this one is reasonable this one is
not 100
Mil maybe this one yeah it's this one
here
but I don't know why there's so many
samples all the way up
here it's doing something clearly
have I mean we have pretty darn good
solves with the other algorithm as well
the new algorithm
I suppose the question is going to be
[Music]
whether the uh the new
one is just not dialed into the level of
the other
experiments or if there's a
gap we'll have to look
close well we'll let the sweep run
before we uh pass final judgment
here so I want to do something a little
different today I want to just work on
some optimization
bit so this is a uh clean up a faster
version of clean ARL that's like six
times faster I think we're five times
faster than this already but there's
some things in here that we haven't done
let's
see there are a few new things
here Vincent
well this is
obvious reason for this stream series I
just stream my Dev dayto day on Puffer C
my goal is to fix reinforcement learning
I want to make everything fast and
stable uh We've made a ton of progress
on this as well so if you just go to
puffer doai you can see we have a dozen
different environments here from very
simple stuff like breakout to very
complex like this mini
MMO and uh all of these things that
you're seeing are agents just playing
the game trained with reinforcement
learning some of them being superum
so we are trying to make a really fast
environment and really good tools to
make it easy to do reinforcement
learning very
fast so at the moment I think we're
going to be doing today some uh
optimization on the training side of the
current Library it's already very fast
but I want to see if there's any more
performance that we can eek out of it
interesting that's
silly so let's see if they found
anything useful in lean RL
here let me load the chat as well so I
can deal with that if I need to
I think when I talked with Vincent I
don't think he had I don't I think he
understood shared memory correctly
um let me see so I want to create a CPU
tensor in P content of this tensor needs
to be placed in
memory we distinguish two types of
memory the RAM and the swap
Bas together these make a virtual
memory okay but you should never be
doing that right
you should never be swapping to dis
anyways regular CPU tensor is pageable
which means it's divided in blocks
called pages that can live anywhere in
the virtual memory both in Ram or on dis
but they're going to stay on
RAM memory seems larger okay when
program accesses a page that's not Ram
page fult
occurs and Os brings this back into RAM
okay this should this is all irrelevant
this should never happen in RL
a pinned memory is a type of memory that
cannot be swapped out to disc okay good
so this is just telling the not to swap
the
memory it's kind of weird to me that it
would swap out the memory in the first
place when you still have plenty of RAM
memory is Page block the device can
access the memory directly in the main
memory the memory is pageable all pages
will have to be brought to the main
memory before being sent to the
GPU Fuda sends pageable data from CPU to
GPU it must create it must first create
a page lock copy of that data before
making the
transfer okay so this is interesting so
when Cuda sends pageable data from CPU
to GPU it must first create a page
locked copy of that
data asynchronous versus synchronous
when executing a copy from host device
tool coolkit to the Cuda toolkit offers
modalities to do these operations
synchronistically or
asynchronously with respect to the host
in practice when call two PCH always
makes a call to Cuda me copy
ASN if nonblocking is false Auda stream
synchronized we called after each and
every Cuda M Copy Asing
okay if nonblocking is true then no
synchronization is triggered and the
main thread on the host is not
blocked so multiple tensors can be sent
to the device on mously as the thread
does not have to wait for one transfer
to be completed to initiate the other so
this is
important in general the transfer a the
transfer is blocking on the device side
even if it isn't on the host
side the copy on the device cannot occur
while another operation is executed
however in some Advanced scenarios a
copy internal execution can be done
simultaneously on the GPU
side three requirements must be met to
enable this the device must have at
least one free direct memory access
engine modern GPU architector have more
than
one the transfer must be done on a
separate non deault Cuda stream in
pytorch Cuda streams can be handles
using
stream The Source data must be pinned in
pinned memory demonstrate this by
running profiles in the following
scripts so okay there's some good stuff
here so you have a
stream you
have pinned and non- pinned
and
then oh I didn't know that these nice
profilers were there
full we will probably be using this
later today in profiling puffer lip
using a pinned memory tensor doesn't
change the trace much both operations
are still executed consecutively can we
see this let's go to review
mode I also want to work in RL and do
research in it myself but I don't have a
good uh good laptop with GPU for
training only have C Core i7 suggest me
what I should do some of puffer's
environments are so fast that uh you can
kind of do training on our environments
on CPU faster than the majority of
researchers can do on GPU so if you just
want to like get into it a little bit
and train some stuff and not have it
take forever uh you can probably still
train a few of our environments in maybe
it takes 5 10 minutes like our stuff is
really fast you probably can still do
training at like 100,000 steps per
second for breakout or
calm for context on a modern core each
of these environments runs a million
steps per second we use the GPU to get
300,000 to a million step per second
training but for the smaller models you
can often still train at 100K just on a
like even on just a
I also have a quick start guide on the
website that I highly highly recommend I
mean I literally wrote it for people who
want an easy way to get into RL so let's
go to blog quick start guide It's like a
20 minute read links you to some other
is okay cool so now we can see this
um and I actually should go back to here
so you can see it
properly okay at 10
2 to copy and then we can see that this
little Gap here this is the overhead of
whatever the P torch binding is and this
is the whole cud M Copy
okay this is the first
one
okay sending a pageable tensor to GPU on
a separate stream
is also a blocking
operation streamed equals
true only pinned tensor copies only
pined tensor copies to GPU on a separate
stream overlap with another Cuda kernel
executed on the
on a separate stream though so how do
you use this stream
thing with to torch Cuda stream s ah you
have to manually manage these things
that's
annoying okay but it's not that hard to
deal with
go high torch perspective pin memory
High torch offers the possibility to
create and send tensors to page lock
memory through the pin memory
method and Constructor arguments CPU
tensors on a machine where food is
initialized can be pinned cast to pin
memory though the pin through the pin me
memory method in memory is blocking on
the main thread of the host it waits for
the testor to be copied to page lock yes
you should never be doing pin memory in
a loop or something anyways that's dumb
new tensors can be created in pin memory
with functions like zeros on and other
Constructors let's check the speed of
sending pin of pinning memory and
sending tensor to
Cuda pageable tensor pin memory. two
device yeah so this is stupid if you're
doing this you don't know what you're
doing uh pageable tensor do2 device the
Baseline and then you save 20% uh if it
is pinned
cool so contrary just a somewhat common
believe calling pin memory on a pageable
tensor before casting the GPU should not
bring any significant speed up and
should be slower okay yeah if you're
doing this you just don't understand
your Hardware yo how's it going
Spencer we're going to perf optimize the
crap out of puffer
today we're going to see if we can hit 2
million train SPS on
something I just haven't done this in
many months so I figure I'd take a day
to do
it non blocking is true
okay to act account accurately of the
benefit of using nonblocking we'll
design a slightly more complex
experiment since we want to assess how
fast it is to send multiple
tensors to GPU with and without calling
nonblocking
okay 2 okay so it's not magic you know
there's like 20 25% overhead sometimes
with
synchronization to get a better sense of
what is happening here oh feeling pretty
confident on the portability of GPU
drive only got one more thing to clarify
with how the data set gets loaded and
should be
clear great I also I went to Brennan's
defense yesterday Brennan is the uh the
author of
Madrona um we'll see if he has ideas on
GPU drive for the madona version but I
think regardless that our CPU version is
just going to be awesome to have um
because regardless right it will make
the project faster F even if they get it
to work in madona ours will run on web
which theirs will not right ours will be
easier to use because it won't require
all the C++ Shenanigans and this is also
an opportunity for us to figure out
variable agent stuff in C uh which will
then let us make a whole new class of
environments and also I think that in
the process of doing this you're
probably going to have to do stuff like
go look at mad drona's uh bounding
volume hierarchy thing which is
how they handle uh lots of entities in
3D and that will be an amazing piece to
have uh for puffer in see so I think we
can just use some of those things in
like portm to see and then we'll have
way way way more flexibility with
working with all sorts of 3D
environments in the future so I think
that you're like if this is the type of
stuff you're interested in yeah this is
really going to be at the frontier of
how do we make uh fast M's work I got to
chat with Brandon actually on what he's
planning to do going forward cuz he's
got some cool
tack some really exciting ways to expand
the M oh yeah lots of
them
definitely it's kind of funny I realized
watching brenan's defense y yesterday
that like the stuff he's doing is way
way way more sophisticated than what I'm
doing with puffer lip right um you know
he's written like a Cuda game engine
basically uh
but the stuff that we're doing is like
so much more flexible and it's still
fast for so many different domains and
it's so much easier to do
right so I don't know there are
definitely things that we cannot do uh
that he can do with like his uh with his
approach that I want to think about like
we've never tried software rendering for
instance um I don't know how fast we
could get like pixel rendering done if
we wanted
to though technically to be fair we
could take uh I think we could just use
their batch renderer so we could because
it like renders from it renders from a
data format that's very similar to what
we have so Tech technically we could
still write the whole Sim on CPU and
then just render on
GPU I think that would still
know you can have every trajectory in
the end be a controllable agent if you
could port a map of La or something then
Rand r l set goals of a [ __ ] ton of cars
yeah no you could definitely I mean if
you want to make you're basically making
high per GTA at that
point it' be sick yeah we'd be happy to
have that that'd be cool that would be
awesome you just have to evaluate how
hard individual things are right and
what Corners to cut and stuff like
memory what are we looking at
here welcome YouTube
folks today is going to be optimizing
the crap out of puffer label all day
we're going to try to hit two million
steps per second training on some of our
environments that's going to be the goal
I don't know if it's even possible but
we're going to try it
uh I'm currently going through this blog
post from Vincent on larl which is an
optimized version of clean RL that's
like five or six times faster puffer Li
is already five times faster than this
but I don't think we're using all the
same optimizations so there might still
be stuff in here first start with board
look into Bing volume hierarchy stuff
it's necessary for a bunch of 3D
collisions yeah they have stuff for
collisions in there now I don't know if
the way that they do it is actually
going to be the best way to do it right
there are a lot of different ways that
you can do that type of stuff um so
you'll have to look at what if the way
that they have it make
sense let's start with uh let's see the
call stack with a regular. two device
first call to device profile memory copy
to device
so there's a whole bunch of garbage here
two copy empty
strided I don't know what any of that
is I still don't know if it's more
efficient to try to emulate the physics
with a good model to train an RL based
model
wait I still don't know if it's more if
to try to emulate the physics with a
good model to train an RL based model
they have really low compute fluid
models two minute papers talked about
this years ago I don't know about any of
that
stuff non-blocking
version call to
device profile
memory and now I don't know what all
these functions are though empty
strided to copy copy
right better when using non-blocking
true as all transfers are initiated
simultaneously so this is 23 Ms 31 Ms of
okay synergies now that we've made the
point that data transfers of tensor
already in pin memory the GPU is faster
and that we know that do the transfers
asynchronously is faster than
synchronously we can Benchmark the
combination of these
approaches first let's write a couple of
new functions that we'll call pin memory
and two device on each
tenser oh yeah also one thing I've been
wondering guys just for this stream does
the mic sound substantially better if I
move it
closer like if I do this is it is this
substantially better
now that we've made the point the data
transfers okay
so I'll look into this I think I thought
of a way to update on every simulation
run just by running multi- agency
framework to change circuit parameters
and get rid of bad Sims quickly that'd
be cool yeah anything you can do to make
Sim faster is usually really helpful in
RL
we can Benchmark the combination of
these approaches okay so pin plus
async pin memory are more pronounced for
somewhat large batches of large
tensors okay so this is a very very
optimistic benchmark
okay so it can be two or three times
faster in a very optimistic case
here favorite RL Benchmark right
now uh Benchmark all the benchmarks
suck all the benchmarks really suck at
the moment what we're doing is we are
just kind of using our environments in
puffer lib uh as they are in their
current form so puffer lib we're not
providing RM is like a stable Benchmark
right like they will keep we will keep
updating them and we will keep fixing
bugs and we're not doing historical
versioning and all sorts of shenanigans
the idea is that at any point in time if
you have two methods right that you want
to compare you just train them both on
our environments and you see what you
get and the training is so fast that you
can do that you know you can do that and
we don't really need to have like an old
historical copy
um but yeah puffer lib RM are what we're
using we will be doing like some uh
external runs I'd say on like Atari and
proen and stuff but we're not going to
do optimization like we're not going to
do hyperparameter sweeps I don't think
anymore over original atar your proen
it's just you're wasting
compute it's so bloody
slow until now we've operated under the
assumption that asynchronous copies from
the CPU to the GPU are safe
what this is generally true because Cuda
automatically handles synchronization to
ensure that data is being access is
valid at read time whenever the tensor
is imp pageable memory in other cases we
cannot make the same assumption when a
tensor is placed in pin memory mutating
the original
copy after calling the host to device
transfer May corrupt the data received
on GPU
when a transfer is achieved in the
opposite
direction there's no guarantee that the
data read on GPU is
valid without explicit
what in these scenarios the transfers
offer no assurance that the copy will be
complete at the time of data
access consequently the data on the host
might be incomplete or incorrect
let's demonstrate this with a pin to
memory so if you
complete then you corrupt the original
tensor
stupid this thing should have a flag set
that tells
you that it's being used or something
that's
Vincent instead of writing a blog post
on this fix it in pie torch
please it should not
happen let demonstrate that Cuda CPU
also fails to produce reliable outputs
without synchronization now it's so
weird when you have like some big like
python uh front-end framework you kind
of expect everything to work and not
fail in weird ways like
this is the type of stuff that's allowed
to happen if I'm working in C right
because I expect that type of stuff to
happen and I'm not going to like like
this is the type of thing that you would
get stuck on for hours because you
wouldn't expect this to be possible in
something where you check it way earlier
if this were like a C++ run end or
something you just check it way earlier
and assume that something could be
screwy Cuda to CPU also fails to produce
reliable
outputs asynchronous copies to device
are safe without explicit
synchronization only when the target is
a c enabled device and the original
tensor is imp pageable
memory
great in general non blocking is true
will be good
throughout provide good
throughput if tensor is already in
pinned memory transfer can be
accelerated sending it to pinned memory
manually from python main thread is a
blocking operation on the host and hence
will annihilate much of the benefit of
using nonblock
trip one might now legitimately ask what
use there is for pinned pin memory
method in the following section we will
explain
how this can be used to accelerate the
data transfer even
more High torch notoriously
notoriously provides a data loader class
whose Constructor accepts a pin memory
argument considering our previous
discussion on pin memory might render
how data loader manages to accelerate
data transfers memory pting is
inherently blocking the key lies in the
data loaders use of separate thread to
handle the data from pageable pinned
memory thus preventing any blockage in
the main thread to illustrate this we
will use tensor dict
primitive the homon from the
whole I didn't realize there was
a adjective form of
homonym
homonymous homonymous that's very weird
all right I didn't know that I learned a
new form of a word today and invoking
two the default behavior is to send
tensors to the device
asynchronously followed by a single car
call to torch device synchronize
afterwards I just is this actually a
word this is bothering
me huh that
is I didn't realize there was an
adjective form of that that's funny uh
invoking
two default behaviors to send tensor to
device asynchronously followed by a
single call to torch device synchronize
afterwards
okay 10.2 includes a non-blocking pin
option which initiates multiple threads
to
execute pin memory before proceeding
with thatu
though oh that is kind of interesting to
be
fair what are you linking
see the question is at which at which of
these layers can you do work quickly
enough like what is the furthest layer
back that you can do work quickly enough
to build massive things solo efficiently
and I think the line is right about here
with maybe a little bit of assembly
H actually to be fair it might it might
be easier than for normal code
agents non blocking pin
okay so this is all tensor dick
stuff again this is optimal case for
tensor
dict no one siiz fit all
solution need to have number of
available cores memory C
device okay
cool nice blog post so
don't Sensers without two if you can
instantiate them avoid pinning memory
unless you thoroughly tested well that's
just the don't pin and then do two avoid
calling tensor do item in between Cuda
operations this triggers Cuda
synchronization and blocks your code D
logging after all code has been
completed see how to find sync points
here okay
cool avoid frequent calls to eval or
train in eager mode we don't do
that avoid calls to avoid calling args
do attribute often in the
what avoid calling ARS do attribute
often in the code especially with
Hydra is python config are like python
config libraries so bad that that is
slow that's OB that's like actually
disgusting Inplay operations are not
preferable to regular
ones don't load your code if not
absolutely
nice now that's only one of the uh the
things here there's also
capturing the operations executed on a
Cuda device using device buffers and
replaying the same operations
later the buffers are updated in place
new results can be
generated here's how a typical kaph
pipeline
look for calls to Tor compile and toog
graph module within theore torch compile
scripts
so pytorch
implementation then lenar
implementation then compil does nothing
but then compile with cphs doubles
lstms
aha I don't think he
did is there an lstm in
here there's not an lstm in here he
didn't get it working with
lstms that is
painful um I might be able to get the
forward pass working with
lstms let's see what uh what he did
here
soode statistics here's your
agent it's j
begin torch compiler cograph marks that
again and he doesn't Mark the end so
assumedly it's the bottom
end Cuda graph module
here so Mark step again roll
interesting now the question I'm going
to have is how much time does this add
to your launch
do Dev branch has a couple things we're
still experimenting
with I'm just going to get this to run
and then I got to go do a thing real
quick
and then uh I will be
back in a few minutes and we will
continue
here okay so current version is 900k
train update
EPO uh this mini batch size is too small
though I mean too big
okay apparently not cool so we will
start with there that's our starting
point and uh I will be back in a few and
we will optimize one
so first thing I want to figure out I
thought that this thing could train at
1.2 million though maybe that was just
breakout I think this one got up to
about a
million with optimal settings let me
see so
multipro
thing oh yeah this is a very
different environment isn't it that we
have here I don't see why it would be
different
though this is 4096 the same
end we could do pong or breakout instead
but I think I think this is probably
this tells you all the pie torch
operations
this looks like what we want for
profiling
where did this width profile come from
is this just torch. profile
where's this freaking activi going come
from now
where's this Trace
Handler export Chrome
let's see if we actually can get some
graphs out of this thing
uh this is going to be too long
obviously 10
mil should be
profiles okay it's printing stuff but
it's all messed up
it's printing stuff and it's crushing my
perk to the point that I don't even
trust what it's profiling anymore
this thing is saying that there's 3x
time spent in CPU versus Cuda but it's
also crushing my perf with the profiling
overhead so who
knows there a problem with a lot of
these profilers
we can see here
the actual backward passes look like
they don't take up any time at
how do we get some stats out of this
thing
uh so this literally just gives you
device synchronized which doesn't
cool export Chrome
trace and then you can
[Music]
examine so apparently we can take these
files
let's take like Trace eight give it a
little time to warm up Trace
cool so we can actually look at
these I'm going to
right okay I I actually don't know what
the hell's going on with this thing
thing ah very intuitive alt plus Mouse
wheel very
intuitive but we can see the uh the
profiles here I
this is all idle in here for some
reason what the heck do we do with this
why do we have idle
like big idle
blocks ah so here's the launches the
kernel
launches so we can
see the actual the launches here are a
big chunk of
perf okay
multinomial I can see the multinomial
here is
expensive this doesn't really give me
any information though on what to what
to uh pursue now does
it let me try something
else I had a different profile I could
try that doesn't give me much
information at
all for
are you
profiling I don't think I have torch 26
right
now oh no I am I have forch 26 I haven't
seen any difference At All by the way I
haven't seen any difference in per
discreet yeah that seems like a bug with
torch or something
I think what we should do here that will
be much more useful than
this is to just expand on our
built-in our built-in profiling
well I can always just expand it for now
right and then I can format this cleanly
later
if you could add that's what I'm doing
right now
I don't know why I have this done with
yields like this this is kind of insane
here so this should run immediately
right
copy uh training should be entirely on
device but let me just run this to just
get an initial test
okay there we can see copy is at
1% but it's not
man hey
welcome when was that reward clamping
added fairly recently it was needed for
breakout like breakout just didn't work
without it so we just added it generally
to the dev branch
copying I think what we get to do is we
do this then we do this goes at the
weird I think before we optimize we
should make sure we actually have all
the profile if we want
what other profile I don't I don't
necessarily know we need more metrics
but I want to make sure everything's
classified correctly and every Line's
profiled
update should be using a c to tensor to
index that's
and we're going to have to clean all
this [ __ ] up up a whole bunch I'm sure
I think I put too much under eval copy
didn't
ah hold on this is uh quite significant
right 28
isn't there a thing where like indexing
with Cuda tensor is
slow e
oh that's actually probably a big one
right here is this
indexing
yeah this definitely needs to be uh
special
cased so returning these
indices is going to make it
slower for
sure now I would like to figure out
first the indexing problem
so we we definitely have clear
actionable stuff that we can improve on
this
today
definitely in fact I think this should
be quite major
uhhuh well let's see where this thing
gets
used it gets used it does get put in
store
so if I just do let's just do
um no
Cuda n
be we're not using e3b we're not going
to worry about that this is going to be
Cuda by
anything that immediately speeds us up
to over a million SPS 1.1
million so this does
something cool we are definitely
definitely going to be able to make this
this Library much
faster I know people are starting to
creep up to puffer and performance a
little bit no puffer will be
fastest in fact I think that's a good
enough result to uh to tweet to get some
people to join to stream to watch this
stuff because this will be fun
I'm going to go grab a drink at least
before Bo I twe that one
okay I'm very happy with that but I
don't
understand what it is that screwing this
up
elsewhere so if I put this
oops let's use P30 we're not using
p3o if I put this in here it's slow
right
yeah
holy yeah that's very slow
okay Ah that's it right there it gets
get used for short Keys
only
so yeah this is taking a lot of little
slices of a a Cuda tensor so then this
one actually shouldn't be the Cuda
one we
mask
numpy values mean. CPU
okay so what is our
new our new overhead after
that still at 20% copy
overhead in
eal not good
here man that's going to be tricky
actually think
indexing is going to be fundamentally
slower than
well let's at least first see how much
we're losing because I think we are
losing a lot but I we should probably
confirm that to explain what's going on
here these nids are a list and anytime
you index with a list you have to copy
so there's redundant copy going on here
because of this um but I think we can
get around it if we are a little
tenser maybe you don't need it we can
just
do hi there I've been doing research in
Aral for about 5 years now and I just
recently came across puffer lip I
respect all your work on trying to
improve the experience with
experimenting with ar thank you yeah we
are going to make RL way way way faster
and easier um I think this year you're
going to see it just become way easier
to get RL working on new problems we
have a whole bunch of active open source
efforts on this right now if you're
interested in getting involved join the
Discord we have a lot of open projects
right
now research side engineering side lots
of cool
stuff right now I'm trying to optimize
our training loop I found some uh some
overhead so I think we're going to get
this to be at least a good 20% faster
today maybe
more slice
object right
so that's an
5% I was expecting more oh because of
this
what are up today what are you up to
today I'm per optimizing puffer lip
we're going to make training faster
uh there's overhead right now in the
training Loop that's caused by some of
the fancy indexing we have to
do but I think we can optimize it in
many
cases I'm just playing around at the
moment to see how much overhead there
actually is I've already found a good a
good 20% though that we can definitely
fix
Cuda right we're going to add a thing to
profile so it's easier for me to uh to
see what's going on here we're going to
just add
okay and then now I can actually profile
stuff as I
please we get 15% of time and
copy
with file.
custom uh all this mess of logging
you're seeing is obviously we're not
going to leave the code looking like
this this is just me trying to quickly
profile some
stuff okay so custom here is at
zero let me just
sleep just make sure that this is
actually what it
[Music]
is that might have been too much Fleep
yeah okay so custom here has all the
time if I do that so yes this logging is
working uh when you add slices like we
have here it's not any
overhead so I need to check
for copy eval copy
let's just do this I want to see how
much overhead this
is profile that
custom okay so this custom is only
taking uh 2%
compute so there is overhead here
somewhere that I do not know where it is
right okay custom is about 7% it's about
half of the copy time 8% of the cop uh
half of the copy time a little more
from so far I can't find anywhere else
that's even
here eval forward
right eval
oops maybe it's the fact that there's no
synchronize on
here could that be it
3%
okay so this
assignment this assignment actually does
cost
that's hard
the issue here right is that
um if you always get the nids in
order then this is
fine if you don't there's a
so we are at the point where uh fancy
indexing is one of if not the main
bottlenecks so we know now we have about
5% if we can figure out lftm
State Management we can get about 5%
performance
back um
um and then with eval copy
here this is about 8% performance in
store is there anything we can do to
optimize store let's
true let me make sure that the thing I'm
planning on doing here is safe I think
it is
mutating the original
copy when it transfers from GPU to CPU
there's no guarantee that the data read
read on GPU is
valid
so to Cuda and then this
is Cuda to
CP also fails to produce reliable output
without synchronization
okay so you actually have to synchronize
here as well left
so I think what we do
here me make sure I have all of
these actually let's make sure that uh
the thing is the bottleneck that I think
it is
uh I did already it was a piece of
garbage that Trace profile [ __ ] sucks
man it's so
so I had an idea for this I think we can
do I think we can async all these
transfers if we're
careful do nonblocking equals true but
then you have to be
what does torch RL
guy uh he does he just batches it kind
of does what this is I'm doing
here kind of does what I'm doing
here actions of indices so these are
already on the right device
all off of the device I don't actually
know we should look at
iteratively yeah but mind you so there
are some tricks we can use in Lan RL the
main one is we're not compiling it all
so they are three fast three times
faster than clean RL without compiling
we are 30 times faster than clean our
all out from
here okay cool so now we have to do
torch. c.
synchronize
doesn't dot CPU it should
take that should take non-blocking
right yeah there is for some reason you
can't do non-blocking on CPU but you can
do it on the device
okay so that actually does help we just
got back
uh a couple percent from that as
think pretty small optimization but it's
that it is an
optimization back to gift making good
luck see you
how much are we losing from this sort oh
yeah we're losing uh or this extend
we're losing a lot okay
really just from this one as one
operation
okay let's figure out this piece of code
here
zero okay so this is 4% right here
right 5%
5% the
pend m key start plus I and
stuff
huh that's funny but yeah that's that's
totally
legit Python's just really
slow um let me think how to do something
about
maybe you can't pre-allocate the swort
casys
well you can pre-allocate storage for
them but you don't know hang
on it's not it's just python being crap
is all it is
along I think we can do it as a numpy
race we can allocate the storage but I
don't it's not the storage that's the
issue it's the uh the iteration
in setting
numpy AR raise is also
slow let me try let me see one other
thing here before I go into this too
much so there because there's a second
problem
okay yeah that's
it 177% yeah we can get rid of
you know this was very very efficient
when puff Li was training at 100,000
steps per second but not so much when
you're training at a
keys so you collect data the order you
collect data in is not predictable um
because we have a synchron
simulation so this is used to tell you
uh essentially to figure out how to sort
all the
data so that you can train on it in the
correct
order oh hold on that's doesn't the way
I did this doesn't make sense does it
pointer on
good this
works and then sort
uh oh how'd that
happen 31's at the
but there should not be multiple zeros
like that
either now there should not be multiple
zeros e
oh is it sorting the rows
separately yes probably sorting these
separately
oh but this is
correct it is correct it's a mess but
it's correct so we will see
we'll probably want to do this so we can
eliminate the
cast but let's
okay that is
slower that is slower
sort if I just do this let me see if
this is
faster oh
yeah so it's all coming from this one
sort line which is great because we just
have to figure out how to make this
work so I need to sort by multiple
columns
well this is freaking wrong so that
doesn't help me now does it
this is fiddly but there's 30% perf on
the table here
Keys is that right
on seems
correct I'm a little confused as to how
this
works
because I think make
sure you sort by
H
sort
Keys star
one sort Keys star
two that's really weird no this
isn't short
oh so it is actually the interface to
this is just backwards okay I'm not
crazy it's just that the interface to
this thing is backwards cool
um yeah that's that's totally fine
do you think Raab will be sufficient of
course why wouldn't it
be Ra's
great have you seen their pie game
interface it's literally just um I mean
you can decide whether you want to do
like a snazzy 3D one or not but this is
their P game interface oh this isn't
even their P game interface their P game
interface is too
where is
already there's still a fair bit of
overhead I
seeing and we haven't even touched
compile yet
use a restro real quick I'll be back in
a minute and then we'll keep looking for
more stuff to
what happened to my uh my screen
let move this on me
lot at least a good chunk of that is
copy overhead
let me see if I can figure out how much
of this
is and then profile.
custom we want to get rid of
this want to
this make sure this is the same
so yeah this is 5% compute on doing
nothing I think
6%
compute I can only
2% torch.
tensor to config DOD
device that's got to be it right there
right that's 2% is moving the OBS onto
the
GPU that's actually pretty
reasonable that's pretty reasonable
got the you forgot the synchronized
call that's not going to work put that
there that there okay
about 4% right
now leaking just on this lstm
I mean that is a single copy
right like this is with uh slicing
why is that so
much
right I mean that's not nothing that's
like
I'm trying to think if there's anything
I can remotely do to fix
that I don't think so not without
breaking the
uh the acing setup I have
anything but at least we're only leaking
4% now not
seven okay so that is 4% of it what
about the rest of this
copy there's still like stuff we're not
getting
okay here's
something storing is now store is now
[Music]
kind of I think there's a very small
optimization we can
do very small optimization we can do
right here
we're going to clean this all up after
we just need to make sure we get the
perf okay so now this way more closely
tracks
there we
go
0% it's got to come from somewhere
doesn't
it says 4% compute
leaking and I'm being told that none of
it's from here
no
ah this is where the computer is huh
okay how is this possibly where the
computer is
that's so funny that's 3% compute saved
literally just by uh replacing some with
a numpy sum
cool well we're at 1.5 million steps per
second which I think is pretty damn
cool that's up uh more than 50% since we
now 0% in
Miss already got to 1.5 what did I
miss just a lot of fiddly debugging um
main things are there's some stuff that
we're doing with indexing there are some
asynchronous device transfers the really
big one was um the way that we were
sorting training data was slow and then
I just found like a random
sum increased speed here like crazy yeah
I just haven't done this in in many
months since like puffer was way slower
and every time you get faster right like
new stuff ends up being the bottleneck
so stuff that didn't matter to optimize
before ma matters
now moving sort to nump yeah well it was
just in it was a python list before
which it doesn't matter when it's a
100,00 things it matters when it's a
million
literally like uh some just to give you
an idea of how much the how fast we're
going here I just replaced uh sum of
duns with duns do sum and I just got a
3% speed
up I guess that Some Loops uh in Python
and nump Loops in
C so you know we're at the point where
really small stuff matters a lot
because python will um like python
actually caps out at a surprisingly low
number of iterations per second like if
you write a really simple program in
Python uh you're going to be capped at
like low tens of millions of iterations
per second Python's just really
slow so you know tens of millions if you
get like 10 million steps per second
right if you have one of those
operations in a million step per second
program that's 5%
overhead and we'll fix that later don't
worry about that one
um crane has a MK as
well compute J
flatten
do well I don't know if I want to look
at this one just yet let me think what
else there is to look at
here
copy what do you think about tiny grad
cool project you know very cool
project he's right pie torch is very
bloated
um they're not doing in eager mode which
is kind of
annoying it's like all it's like all
graph compiled so it's closer to Jax or
something uh without Jax is like God
awful Syntax for the most part it seems
but yeah it seems fine e
probably the next thing to look at is
going to be if there's anything in
forward that shouldn't be
there now forward is just
forward so 52% of the time is in here
huh oh no there's more stuff in forward
hold
all right let me see if I see anything
weird in here that looks like it could
be made faster
multinomial yeah but these list
comprehension Or List comprehensions
over like one thing or like a few
things hang on I just heard let me just
see what the hell that
what's this line take
up Pro the
it's
only that's
when a sample index is drawn for a row
it cannot be drawn
again or that row light what
okay is that 1% faster no it's not it's
the
same I was wondering if this would be
slow with uh replacement or
whatever out
Bing vile you hierarchy
seems well check if you actually need to
do it first before you just naively Port
stuff right like does the thingy do does
the algorithm or whatever does the the
way he's constructing it makes sense is
there a simpler thing that you can do CU
everything's not on crazy GPU
land oh also you don't even have to
implement that thing first right like
you can get the whole thing working end
to end just like checking every object
right so it's quadratic and then you can
like add optimizations from there that's
probably smarter
yeah exactly so just
like you know go like do the simple
thing first and I got to help you with
the data structures as well but I'm
doing this at the
moment I mean I figure if I can spend a
day and get the thing to be more than
50% faster that's probably going to be
pretty darn good
categorical any guesses from what I've
done before on timing to get something
decent with your DS
help do you have like an understanding
of the GPU Drive architecture and
everything already
how long it'll take me to Port High
Level I think I understand
details still reading through I mean it
depends how like how much of the stuff
you add right like the level editor is
going to take a while a lot of things
are going to take a while but like I
don't know I I think I could probably
knock something like basic together in a
few days that kind of looks like a
driving Sim
um it like it really depends how much of
the stuff that you add that is in there
elements given tens are based
on yeah I I don't I remember this being
PR to puffer lib is like a perf
enhancement but I'm looking at this
thing and it's not actually doing
multiple uh like multi- discreete
actions at the same
time so something's weird with this
first input being
tensor tensor to sample
indices like it's the it's you're not
sampling from something right you have a
distribution and then you're picking the
index that's the sample
problems ah so this
uses
multinomial so we just skip this and we
go use multinomial directly okay so then
this is fine
getting something that render the way Mo
set should be relatively easy
yeah it's interesting that there's 8% in
here
ends
okay yeah that uh
H interesting
pass I'm I'm trying to figure something
out 32
here's what I'm trying to figure out
forward
path of the train routine is
14%
okay and in my case it's
network just make sure it's not like all
of a sudden
before okay so there's for some reason
there's this
massive this massive
Gap I'm trying to figure out what it
would be
action unless the train profiler is
wrong
maybe the train profiler is wrong let's
see about
sequence this might be an lstm thing
hang on
reading through stuff this weekend just
ping me yep pretty much
T so without the lstm here tiny little
model trains at 3.2 million steps per
second and then look at that the uh the
forward time is way
closer to the forward
time in uh yeah the forward time is way
closer and now is there scaling here if
I do
812 do we do
21% there's a little bit of scaling
above 8192 it looks like
32k so there's definitely something
going on with uh with the RNN here
time goes up even a little more with
more MS
we see this right though the uh so
forward takes three times longer than
train with the
lstm without the lstm they're roughly
even
I'll be right back give me a minute and
we'll figure this
right I'm trying to think now what could
what could this
be
right just the forward
middle now there's no reason that this
can't go higher
right if we do
this and put this up
copy and then if I do that I can delete
this line right which also means I can
delete this line
so now we don't have the synchronizes in
that's got to be a synchronized bug
right
yeah this a synchronized bug
holy okay so all the
time is in this
function right
here uh also you're a [ __ ]
you put your lstm stuff completely
wrong but now we figured out that it
is profile so
50% half of my time is going into the
policy en
code only 14% is going into it in
but it should be in eight for both of
these
idea let's just profile Thea lstm
call for
well something double counted
right yeah double
so 40%
45% 6% in
here and that's including the other Ford
call so yeah all the time it's just
happening in the lstm
sup doc hey how's it
going we are making some big games and
optimization here
I wonder if this thing has this thing
doesn't contain a cell does
forward okay hold on look there's
something here
so if it is a packed sequence you do
some stuff otherwise
train. no I don't I don't even bother
with that stuff
it should be freaking faster in forward
than backward mode
that doesn't fix
it same Speed without
so if you don't pass it it just makes
zeros for
jeez by George you're not fun to debug
through are
I'm trying to think how we can determine
why this is happening because this is
definitely the biggest spot for
perf at the moment is I don't know why
the lstm is 3x slower at least three
times slower in inference versus
training
hang on maybe there is some
preprocessing that's done that's like
really
slow uh let me
see here is our lstm
right and where's the to call to this so
when you call forward on
weights I don't know why that's
called okay not giving it a packed
sequence input dim
okay is
input this doesn't get
called is
bashed we get this this is
fine per mute hidden
indices wait
each permute indices with sorted
indices sorted indices is none unsorted
indices is
none
huh what
oh okay so this just gets
called by permute
hidden where's permute
hidden yeah they are always none that's
why I was wondering why they were there
def permute
hidden apply
permutation index
select dim
I think I actually have to go to the
freaking torch profiler again how
obnoxious this thing is
you see if there's a simpler one since I
really just need to time this one
function
okay so
here we get the at 10
usually very
high which one's
yeah you can see it here it's this I
don't know what this function is
though native P torch
implementation which is a fallback
well we do have C and this is getting
called
still this is very weird so this is
still getting
called here
misec this is the first call so this
takes
longer and now it's at 300
and now it's at 300 still
okay
fast this
one that might be the last batch or
something this one and then
650 with one exception here right these
are at
650 it's much lower here
end so this is the high level
one so okay this is overhead then
sequences now see the thing is
it's we're still getting the same
time I think that there's some reshape
operation or some [ __ ] happening in
the lstm implementation
lstm
[Music]
oh you are giving it way more data
actually on the hidden State aren't
you that makes sense
maybe it is 3x lower because you're
giving
it instead of just input you're giving
it input and then two different hidden
States
okay but then the setup cost should be
3x not 6X right is it 3x or
6X it's more than
3x e
no there isn't it just made that [ __ ]
up dang it
it's very difficult to know where
uh where this is coming
from no
RNN re okay so there is a
separate function here
right I don't know if it's work working
correctly I think this is separate
though from the lstm
tring think what we can do about
this lstm going
Gru only has one
state does Gru have hold
I have this thing set up for lstms is
the
idea well no even if I pass none it's
still not going to work right
now the issue
is You' think this would be made up for
though what the heck does A10 lstm even
I don't know what the overhead
is the problem
I'm going to think about this
for a bit
um might want to go get some
lunch this is a solid progress we are
already up more than 50%
so I'm going to get some food I'll be
back and then I think we'll probably
mess with torch compile a little bit
first just to see if that evens out the
numbers cuz it's like overhead anyways
so maybe maybe compile bypasses it we'll
see I'm going to go do
that um and I will be back all right